ph
いきなりこんな映像から始まってしまい申し訳ございません
嘘ですこの動画はですねあの家とか
家とか男の裸とか黒いのうわぁ[ __ ]無理だ証ぶりをみたいな人はここで止めておいて
くださいおよげみんな今日はオウムに男性諸軍君たちに話しておきたいてが参考に
してほしいまあいつからなのは俺も気付いた頃にはすでにそっち側の人間だったさ
俺たちの男は大人になるにつれて
兄弟について悩まされでしょそこの君もそうじゃないかに会うの曲が
ってかはてぃもんすんですよ実は僕はチゲもそばと薄いんですけどやっても早いと思う
んで中学校から始まっちゃったし
高校でも結構も曲だすぎてもうヤバイ人もいたし僕はですねその機能多いに襲われたの
は二十歳になってからだったんです形になってから
92ヒゲが仏界出したり解剖がめっちゃ
毛深くなったりして
[音楽]
こうやって人はおっさんになっていくんだなぁ手数で思ってたんですけども今は男でも
脱毛する時代なんですその後って俺は二十歳の時になけなしの金を使って脱毛に行った
があまりの痛さに立つ通ってしまったことがある
ダサいだろだが届いたに打ち勝ってこそビッグもうね仕方ないんですよ痛いもあって
決定入ることでしょ
はいできるものを生えてこなくさせるということはどんどん行け苦しい思いしてんだよ
って言う結局請負た見つけるしかないんでやっぱりたさんは仕方ないんでそこをこらえ
ていくしかないんでまあ一つの参考例として皆には見ててほしい
結局猫のヒゲとかそれた肌
いた分でを買うときの一弦にやはないんでそれだったらたく知っておいた方がいいん
じゃねぇかなぁいろんな要因があって僕は今回
からだ
全部の本当に全部の毛の脱毛に行ってきますね聞いてくださいいろんな理由があるん
ですよいつも言ってるクリニックのお姉さん中締めした0
杭あようやる vi をやるって言われて部や様って何って思ったんですけど日
あげようっていう全シーンとアプリつのデリケートゾーンのことですね陰部の場合の計
はじめシャツお作法やないああいやあ8目社長
絶対行ったほうがいいよみたいなこと言われていただきますってことでやることになり
ました
さあできる床をたつもとにもレーザー食べていたいんですけどいいねまた外へ決議が
本当に一枚板安いです
なんで今回は僕が猛虎の好みを持っていけも体全身ももうっ
ええまあたけ決議も全部やるんでどこがどれくらいたいかっていうのは僕の表情から見
てわかると思うんでそれは今回みなさんにお伝えしようと思います
レーザー脱毛道産子
押してくださいというのも明日レーザー脱毛行ってくるんですけどもレーザー脱毛の
場合にしなきゃいけないことが一つありまして嶺臣の毛を剃ります9してそんなバカ
みたいにこういうわけじゃないんですよね僕もこういう気も去らないと効果がないんで
こういうところ uk
こういう細かい毛とかも全部剃っていきますもちろんような税神の系全部剃ったらどれ
くらい家が魂の
立ってるのちょっとやってみたいと思います僕ですね体の計結構濃いんですよ屋号を
持ってるわけじゃないんですけどまあ人並みに恋スって普通にこいっすぅ水っぽく
見えるんですけど全然スノーがなくて結局何回で脱毛を言って今があるんで全然コイン
で毛が濃いだぜ目さん安心してください
僕の一緒ですジャン全部剃ってきます
腕からやろうか
おっ
none
んん
[音楽]
体負けを全部するのに3時間半かかります全然黒いんでその見なくていいと思うんです
けど大体全部するとこれぐらいの毛の量になりますまあ子犬いっぴぐらいの毛は食べた
と思います
もう基本的に上ではツルツル足もすべすべでございますてかまずケツ毛なんでそっとば
前に見たこともないんでなんか危なかったスンアすごいか良いですこの後病院に行って
きますでは
よ
ん
4日
マジでこう言ってねそれぐらいだから
てもらって
分かったでしょごめんてきた
やっぱりん
はいございまーす
me
入った
rar
[音楽]
dee
me
ina
あので買ってるんですねハッハー
というわけで今から肛門のレーザーだ道です
はいお願いしまーすやっていきたいねちょっとあってくださいちょっと心の準備用品
いうふうに満つれば入っ
メジャーと思いますけど帰って言うだけなら
ウェイクドラッグん
本格のでこれ
ちょっと待ってくださいねー
[音楽]
なるほどそういう数が受けですパッチもさあ行けばあーなるほどだろうとそういう数か
ああああああ
ええええええ
こういうふうには超えました wj
持っています
林孟のレーザー脱毛っています
はい
あーなるほどダルホドは ok でさあ検索しました行けます
まぁちょっと待っていただけませんいけますよナンマンダまたまた
まだここらぬ
まぁでも自分で抜いてた時の痛みをにてる t 建造
感覚があります
あるのだはいが続いてひじれそれじゃあ
[音楽]
ていた
ありがとうございます
どうだったーーバチバチだというもんね
スパ千葉つしてると思うんですけどあんまり言いたくないんですよ花スタンスが
ちょっとビッグってなるけど
tyrell た入れる
[音楽]
終わりました本当に現金列車でこれがあればもう十分ですね
お前ねじゃあ
ましたん
ません
思ったぜん
4日経っていた
かはいというわけでレーザーだと言ってきました
ああっいたいっていうのもそもそも僕はで出力でた最大
max でやってるんでそれはもちろん痛いですまた効果が強いんだったら僕は別に
痛くてもいいかなと思ってる派の人間なんで結構まずで限界レベルでいたかったんです
けど頑張りました
レーザー当てた部分だけっていうかね1週間が2週間くらい経ったからなんかポロ
ポロって落ちてくるらしいのでそしたら綺麗な肌が
できてくるっていう感じでございますはてきれなくて編俺にここだけなくなってほし
いって思ってるわけじゃないんで
まあ程よく薄くなればいいかなくらいだと思いますヒゲは本当にでそれからめんど
くさいし
もし何かそういうケットが気になってる方がいたらこんな感じだよっていうのが分かっ
てくれば良かったです
いいいいいいいいいん
ん